bonjour à tous ici votre art go rock
nationale marvel vient de sortir un
nouveau trailer est bon sens pour la
première fois il ya vraiment du concret
a analysé comment sont sans tarder mais
avant ça pour ceux qui l'auraient loupé
j'ai sorti en compagnie de mon ami aeros
f13 théorie l'ultime sirène games et des
théories fonctionne si on se fie à ce
nouveau trailer c'est une vidéo qui
m'est très cher je vous conseille
vivement d'aller la voir le petit pouce
bleu est également appréciable
allez on y va premièrement malgré que ce
trailer ne fasse qu'une minute je pense
qu'il est celui dont il y a le plus de
choses à dire thanos apparaît enfin et
les héros comme unique réellement entre
eux nous commençons sur les paroles de
banner dans le bâtiment des avengers
affirmant qu'ils sont trop peu et war
machine le confirme
natacha est honni rétorque avec le fait
qu'il faut tout de même essayer et
qu'ils vont réussir
ceux ci affirment qu'il n'y a plus le
choix soit il reste avec seulement la
moitié de l'univers en vie et ils
abandonnent les personnes disparues du
claquement de doigts soit ils agissent
nous ne sommes plus dans une ambiance de
rédemption ou de sacrifices comme lé
premier trailer mais au contraire dans
un objectif de réussite et d'espoir
touchante suite au précédent trailer je
trouve réellement que natacha possède un
rôle de soutien plus qu'autre chose
c'est elle qui à chaque trailer possède
la parole pour motiver à agir et je
pense que c'est quelque chose que nous
reverrons dans le film il est clair que
natacha n'est pas une grande stratège
comme toni ou aussi forte que thor elle
aura son importance mais sera néanmoins
moins au combat que d'habitude
c'est ce que je ressens en tout cas nous
arrivons très vite atonie qui devient un
élément très très central de ce trailer
avec la noce nous le savons les deux
personnages sont comme qui dirait liés
de par leur intelligence et leur
prévoyance ce sont des visionnaires
ce trailer montre pour moi une
confrontation entre le père des avengers
et iron man et le célèbre titan
effectivement tony apporte beaucoup dans
ce trailer nous savons qu'il va au final
revenir assez rapidement sur terre en
compagnie de nebula lé premier trailer
était là pour également nous faire peur
et nous intriguer concernant sa survie
pour justifier son retour sur terre
ce dernier va me faire une
réconciliation officielle avec steve
rogers chose qu'on attendait depuis la
fin de civil war
concernant cette réconciliation steve
depuis le début du plan de communication
de marvel concernant endgame et
énormément de mise en avant comme le
leader des derniers avengers
contrairement à ce trailer qui chamboule
tôt avec l'arrivée de tony qui demande à
steve de lui faire confiance et donc lui
laisser la place de chef du coup comme
quoi marvel nous a caché énormément de
choses
en voyant cette scène on ne peut que se
rappeler du plan du dr strange qui a
totalement saoul été sauvées tony car il
serait utile à son plan celui peut
déceler comment vaincre thanos la seule
possibilité existante sur 14 millions
c'est d'ailleurs stark qui semble
motiver les troupes
affirmant que le plus important est ce
qu'il nous reste tout en enchaînant sur
un plan de tony dans l'une de ses
premières armes sûrs ces paroles peuvent
faire écho au fait que son armure en
nanoparticules a été détruite dans
infinity ward et donc qu'il doit revenir
sur une armure plus ancien c'est
peut-être un message caché et plein de
sens
la chose qui prouve également le retour
rapide de tony et nebula sur la planète
terre et que les avengers utilise
énormément le vaisseau des gardiens dans
les thrillers et certainement pour tout
le long du film
ce sera leur moyen de transport
principal avec évidemment roquettes aux
commandes ainsi que captain marvel
enfin nous arrivons à la partie qui me
hype le plus et qui m'intéresse
énormément le retour de thanos enfin
thanos a été montré et a annoncé ce
dernier fait la morale aux avengers en
leur affirmant qu'il ne pouvait pas
vivre face à leurs échecs
eux qui ont toujours tout gagné depuis
le début du mc hugh quelles que soient
les difficultés
thanos a conscience de tout ça et prouve
encore une fois la longueur d'avancé
qu'il possède sur le reste de nos héros
le titan savez et comme dans la bande
annonce en vo affirme que cette route
allait forcément les mener vers lui de
nouveau il semble les attendre cependant
thanos va perdre pied car je viens de
vous parler de la bande annonce en vo
mais il se pourrait que la vf nous est
mentionné quelque chose d'inédit
à moins que cela soit une simple
manipulation des traileurs mais je ne
pense pas thanos affirme qu'il va
pulvériser cet univers et bon sang il ya
un paquet de choses à dire là dessus
premièrement analysons ce que nous
voyons sur le trailer nous pouvons
remarquer ce qui semble être le combat
ultime face à la noce avec pour champ de
bataille
certainement la base des avengers
totalement détruite
il est clair qu ngame signera la fin de
l'épopée thanos et nous verront le jour
sur quelque chose de nouveau
la destruction de la base des avengers
pourrait signifier la fin du concept en
lui même que les abeilles gers
n'existeront plus mais auront à nouveau
nom avec de nouveaux héros etc bref
thanos semble être à terre en compagnie
de sa lourde épée dont je vous avais
parlé dans nos trois théories ultime
le titan est en perte de vitesse
l'utilisation de son épais comme je vous
le disais peut signifier que le titan va
beaucoup moins utiliser les pierres mais
je vous laisserai voir ma vidéo sur le
sujet justement nous sommes face au
retour des trois piliers principaux des
avengers soit tony steve et or mais dans
leurs tenues d'origine ceci peut prouver
clairement le voyage dans le temps ou du
moins à travers le monde quantique en
parlant du monde quantique d'ailleurs
nous n'avons vu à aucun moment les
nouvelles combinaisons des avengers
montré dans le précédent trailer
ceci prouve que ces tenues ne sont que
temporaires et possède une utilité
unique
je vous le mets dans le mille le voyage
quantique danos affirme qu'il va
détruire cet univers s'il dit cet
univers cela veut dire qu'il y en a
d'autres
confirmant que les avengers aurait
voyagé à travers les dimensions et bien
c'est fortement possible
enfin si nous revenons à thanos il
semble être très loin de son but de
départ s'il souhaite détruire l'univers
et j'ai trois scénarios pour vous
expliquer pourquoi le titan a dit cette
phrase
premièrement thanos tout comme les
avengers à leurs débuts a tout gagné
dans infinity ward toutes les batailles
soit la récolte de chaque pierre est
compris la guerre soit le combat ultime
contre les abus
georges ici dans le trailer il semble
être en perte de vitesse
la colère pourrait justifier cette
phrase du coup deuxièmement thanos a
toujours affirmé qu'ils souhaiteraient
après une finity war se reposer et voir
se lever un nouveau jour sur un univers
reconnaissant en outre le fait que le
mot univers est également repris il est
évident que beaucoup envient la noce et
souhaite sa mort personne n'est
reconnaissant envers ce qu'il a fait il
n'a donc plus rien à perdre en tuant
tout le monde dernièrement et c'est la
raison que je pense la plus probable
c'est que les personnes tuées par le
snap ont été ramenés thanos possède
toujours son gant et les pierres mais
rappelez-vous des dégâts provoqués par
le claquement de doigts thanos ne peux
certainement plus effectuer un nouveau
snap
donc si les personnes disparues ont été
ramenés est en hausse a perdu échange
donc d'objectifs soient pulvérisés
l'univers pour qu'ils cerise est
néanmoins il utilisera toujours les
pierres mais ne pourra plus les utiliser
pleinement suite à sa blessure et le
gant qui est très amoché nous voyons
d'ailleurs utilisé la pierre de l'espace
pour se téléporter
enfin bref cela prouverait en quelque
sorte l'utilisation de son épée enfin
voilà j'avais beaucoup de choses à dire
j'ai eu peu de temps j'espère vraiment
que cette vidéo vous aura plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à activer
la cloche et me laissait un gros pouce
bleus qui est grandement mon travail
pouvez également vous abonner me suivre
sur twitter et me soutenir via utile
j'en peux plus vraiment d'attendre une
game et je pense que marvel devrait
arrêter à partir de maintenant les
trailer de peur de trop en dévoiler mais
il reste 22 jours il se peut qu'un
quatrième trailer comme celui là sortent
mais c'est pas plus mal
je vous l'avais je vous invite de
nouveau avoir mon trois théories ultime
sereine games qui est clairement la
vidéo la plus complète que j'ai pu faire
concernant le film et qui rejoint
quasiment toutes les vidéos théorique
que je vous avais proposé par le passé
bref c'était votre dévoué argot rock et
que le lay honneur soit avec vous
[Musique]